lever la main si vous voulez sauver les
ours blancs
ok lever la main si vous voulez que
l'arctique arrête de fondre lever la
main vous le sentez venir un levé la
main si vous êtes prêts à jeter votre
smartphone plus jamais on utilisait plan
30 ans évidemment il ya des fayots donc
merci merci aux failles au d'avoir levé
la main c'est très important pour moi
d'être là ce soir au partager avec vous
ce message parce que on est à grenoble
et grenoble c'est presque une ville une
ville phare pour la question de
l'hydrogène il se passe tellement de
recherche tellement de choses
historiquement et aujourd'hui sur
l'hydrogène à grenoble et du coup j'ai
envie de vous parler d'hydrogène ma
spécialité les questions polaires et
puis dans le même temps que j'ai envie
de vous dire que le futur c'est une
construction sociale
je vais pas faire un million de vues en
racontant genre de bêtises en tout cas
j'espère que je vais les faire est ce
que vous arrivez à lire ce mot il y en a
qui ont fait japonais ici parfait alors
ça c'est à sliimy rails mais l'ice ça
veut dire le futur ça veut dire futur
est en fait le problème qu'on a le
problème que vous avez collectivement on
l'a tous c'est qu'en fait le futur
n'existe pas c'est à dire que si vous
faites de la prospective ce que vous
allez faire c'est que vous allez partir
d'un temps dans le passé pour essayer de
comprendre ce qu'il va se passer dans le
futur mais dans ce futur là vous allez
projeter des droites faire des tendances
vous allez essayer de comprendre qu est
ce qui peut se passer mais aurait été
vous en avais pas la moindre idée
et ce qui est assez fantastique c'est
quand je dis que le futur n'existe pas
c'est qu'en fait le futur c'est
intangible c'est évanescent vous croyez
le chopper là il est là et hop il part
comme des grains de sable
il vous échappe et c'est normal qui vous
échappe parce qu'en fait le futur vous
moi tout le monde on construit tous au
quotidien
c'est à dire qu' il n'y a pas de futur
vers lequel il faudrait attendre la
réalité des choses c'est que
tout simplement vous voulez anticipez
vous voulez maximisez votre position
vous voulez que votre pays soit plus
fort vous voulez gagner plus d'argent
vous voulez retrouver l'être aimé tout
ce que voulait et pour faire ça vous
allez essayer d'anticiper des actions
vous allez dire il faut que je fasse ici
pour obtenir ça le problème c'est qu'en
fait le futur c'est la somme de toutes
ces petites anticipation quelque chose
dont on ne sait pas que ça va arriver et
qui petit à petit va créer une réalité
complètement alternative donc dans
laquelle on est bien obligé de vivre et
du coup il ya un terme en innu petit
tout pour ça alors une petite août c'est
la langue des inuits du nord est du
canada
pas tous et ça il ya quelqu'un qui peut
le lire à quelqu'un que tu as fait une
petite ou de deuxième langue
non personne très bien je vais vous
aider même si j'ai pas fais une petite
deuxième langue
cette liste sont beauty nique et donc ça
ça veut dire s'adapter s'adapter en fait
c'est ça le terme
le terme important au-delà de
l'anticipation c'est l'adaptation en
fait à toutes ces choses qu'on n'avait
pas prévu et qu'ils vont se passer qu'on
le veuille ou non voire même les
rétroactions des actions qu'on fait
aujourd'hui que l'on ne sait pas qu'on
va devoir les survenir demain et donc du
coup le véritable problème c'est que
quand on parle de transition énergétique
de transition digital on se dit super
c'est le progrès c'est le progrès c'est
vrai j'ai un smartphone
j'ai je sais pas combien d'ordinateurs
ça m'aide au quotidien à travailler y en
a qui font de l'intelligence
artificielle qui font des robots etc
c'est top non sauf que le problème c'est
tout ça qu'on parle d'éolien qu'on parle
de solaire qu'on parle de robot de
datacenter qu'on parle de facebook
d'autres choses youtube
ça nécessite des terres rares à un
moment et c'est tout l'enjeu qu'on va
devoir traiter en arctique
alors pourquoi pas tout simplement parce
que dans les terrains vous avez lettera
légère les terres rares lourdes veux pas
rentrer dans des tailles de tous je vais
pas vous faire une certaine sion sur le
dysprosium etc etc
mais par contre ce que je vais vous dire
simplement c'est que quoi que vous
fassiez aujourd'hui si vous voulez
transitionner avec des émotions verte
où vous voulez transitionner avec des
émotions violette
quelles que soient les couleurs que vous
mettez derrière la transition
énergétique et digital vous allez avoir
besoin d'un moment de terres rares et le
problème c'est que aujourd'hui le marché
des terres rares si on se focalise sur
cette géopolitique toute particulière et
terreur c'est quoi c'est une famille de
17 métaux critiques
on va les prendre collectivement
aujourd'hui la chine contrôle entre 80
et 90% du marché mondial donc autrement
dit à un moment donné dans la chaîne de
valeur au début la chaîne de valeur au
début du tout de la transition
énergétique et digital vous passez par
les chinois et vous n'avez pas le choix
aura peu de choses près 20% du marché
est en fait les grands qui pensent
aujourd'hui au futur de la transition
énergétique et digital il regarde
évidemment dans le fond des océans
mais il regarder ça qui va nous
intéresser aussi surtout ce soir
et puis dans les années qui viennent à
l'article s'intéresse à l'arctique ce
que vous voyez sur cette carte c'est
tout simplement les grands projets
miniers de terres rares qui vont être
ouverts c'est à dire mis en exploitation
dans les dix prochaines années
même si on peut pas prévoir le futur là
quand même
il ya un certain nombre de signes qui
nous laisse penser que ça va se faire
notamment des contrats signés des
investissements faits par exemple le
problème c'est que donc au début de la
chaîne de valeur vous avez cette terreur
qui quand elles sont extraites du sol
pour lui énormément ce que vous voyez
ici c'est la pollution qui est générée
par l'extraction de une tonne seulement
une petite tonnes de terres rares
ça fait beaucoup la végétation malades
des sols contaminés des résidus des gaz
contenant des acides et ainsi de suite
mon but n'est pas de vous faire peur ce
soir c'est juste de vous dire ça c'est
une réalité
et puis ensuite à la fin de la chaîne de
valeur quand on est sur notre smartphone
donc il ya plein de terres rares et
qu'on clique par exemple qu'on lie qu'un
truc sur sur un stade où on envoie un
snap
pas de fête on recompte sommes encore on
émet du co2 on réutilise des
infrastructures des câbles des
datacenter et ainsi de suite descente
ce qui nécessite des terres rares mais
peut-être qu'à une solution alors là je
sais pas si quelqu'un reconnaisse qu'il
ya derrière moi mais ce qu'il ya
derrière moi j'espère qu'à grenoble
beaucoup le reconnaissent ses l'atome
d'hydrogène
tout simplement l'élément le plus simple
le plus fascinant de plus abondant de
l'univers mais qu'on n'a pas sur terre à
l'état naturel parce qu'ils par exemple
en 1799 on est au coeur de la révolution
française
évidemment je prends la révolution
française au sens large un chimiste
spécialiste des gaz d'éclairage
hélas ce type philippe le bon français
il arrive à obtenir un brevet de la part
de la mairie de paris on est en 1799
c'est le bordel et sait faire cette
petite invention de gaz d'hydrogène là
donc c'est en fait une destination du
bois pour faire simple et je vais la
mettre dans les lampadaires
vous aviez jamais cru que l'ayant pas
l'air mauvais si fascinant je crois que
là ça c'est la première occasion à
laquelle on ne trouve de l'hydrogène qui
a été façonnée et utilisé en politiques
publiques
on est en 1799 en il ya plus de 200 ans
déjà donc c'est pas nouveau
levings lagos et is le thème de notre
conférence on est dans cette notion
d'héritage et puisse aller plus loin
donc il est décédé en 1804 sauf que
évidemment les travaux ont continué en
1804 on a créé les premiers moteurs à
hydrogène à base de gaz de houille cette
fois ci donc c'est plus du bois c'est du
distillat de charbon et puis en 1839
iasi holbein qui arrivent et qui dit moi
je vais j'ai trouvé des propriétés
spéciales qui font qu'en fait quand on
fait passer un courant électrique dans
l'eau ben le lot vous savez c'est ch2o
un bain le h2 là donc c'est à dire la
molécule de 10 hydrogène les deux atomes
d'hydrogène se sépare de l'atome
d'oxygène
ria bhl g de l'hydrogène je peux la
manufacture et ça a l'air incroyable sur
le papier garder ça dans un coin de
votre tête cette fois important pour la
suite et puis quelques années plus tard
en fait plus de quatre décennies plus
tard il ya un autre français etienne le
noir qui dit bon ben moi je sais je suis
allé encore plus loin et j'ai fait cette
première voiture à hydrogène heures
c'est pas vraiment une voiture
c'est ce qu'on appelle une hippomobile
parce que je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez mais à l'époque
dans paris on est tracté en carriole par
des chevaux je vous raconte pas l'odeur
mais ça c'est un autre sujet peut-être
qu'un a qui aiment ça qui ont fait des
excitations ce qui est important surtout
c'est de se dire est ce qu'on peut se
débarrasser des chevaux ça coûte cher
des chevaux le cocher la bouffe
l'entretien c'est important comme
ressource économique le cheval si on
peut passer à l'hydrogène avec le petit
moteur qui est derrière nous c'est
intéressant et donc du coup il a fait un
démonstrateur il a fait il a fait paris
joinville le pont c'est à dire 9 km mais
après je vous demanderais d'être
indulgent avec lui parce qu'on est quand
même en 1883 quoi donc avec vos yeux de
2019 vous êtes bien sympa est ce que
vous aurez pu faire la même chose
et la question qui se pose ensuite c'est
mais pourquoi on a pas on n'est pas allé
plus loin
eh ben on n'est pas allé plus loin parce
qu'il ya eu d'autres trucs entre temps
il ya eu du pétrole et du gaz qui a eu
et réciter à grande échelle
donc du coup on se retrouve en 1953 la
filière hydrogène a pas beaucoup évoluer
là dessus et pour la mobilité en tout
cas et du coup il ya un type qui
arrivent et qui dit ben moi j'ai fait la
première pile à combustible un kilowatt
en laboratoire c'est bien alors la pile
à combustible tout le monde voit à peu
près ce que c'est non c'est bien pour
tourner à grenoble en gros la pile à
combustible très simple pour faire un
pays hyper hyper schématique vous allez
rassemblé tout simplement le h2 et le
haut et vous allez dégagez l'énergie en
les rassemblant et ça va faire tout
simplement de la vapeur d'eau pas de co2
c'est quand même pas mal
puis tout ça ça occasionnait un certain
nombre de deux prochaines journées en
1991 le sommet sur le climat de rio en
1992 des nations unies arrivent
just around corner comme on dit et mazda
constructeur japonais au salon de
l'automobile de tokyo présente après dix
ans de recherche son premier prototype
de moteur à pile à combustible qui
pourrait être un moteur grand public
et là on a touché quelque chose parce
que là on a peugeot bmw mercedes toyota
tout le monde qui dit c'est quoi ce truc
c'est génial et vous allez me dire mais
c'est quoi le rapport avec l'article
évidemment donc le rapport avec
l'article c'est ça vous savez tous que
l'arctique fond jusque là et pas de
problème là ce que vous voyez sur cette
animation de la nasa
c'est la fonte de l'arctique entre 1984
et septembre 2019 donc ces 35 dernières
années
est ce que vous voyez tout simplement
c'est angry les glace qui se forme l'été
qui se forment l'hiver pardon et qui
font de l'été et en blanc ce que vous
voyez est ce qu'on appelle les classes
de banquise puisque c'est la glace de
mer pluriannuel donc c'est de la glace
qui va se former un hiver qui va
survivre à au moins un été et qui va
être là encore un deuxième hiver qui a
peut-être même survie deux hivers deux
étés pardon et qui va faire deux ans
trois ans quatre ans cinq ans et en fait
ce que oui tout simplement c'est qu'au
fur et à mesure cette glace
pluriannuelle disparaît et plus cette
glace pluriannuelle disparaît plus il
est difficile pour la banquise arctique
de se reformer et plus il est difficile
pour la banquise arctique de se reformer
plus tout simplement l'océan chauffe
puisque l'océan
dépourvu de banquise ne peut plus avec
le blanc de la banquise refléter les
rayons du soleil vers l'atmosphère donc
chauffe et à partir de là bas ça
s'aggrave et la fonte s'accélère et
c'est ça le véritable drame de
l'arctique c'est cet effet boule de
neige permanent qu'on voit sur les
glaces de mer qu'on voit sur les glaces
de terre les carottes qu'on voit sur les
terres gelées le permafrost et ainsi de
suite
prenez juste un petit mot
pour regarder cette fonte dites vous que
chaque fois que vous cliquez sur un sur
install poste instar didukh à chaque
fois que vous achetez un ordinateur
si par exemple d'un véhicule électrique
à batterie ça vous intéresse si je sais
pas moi une trottinette électrique ça
vous intéresse
bon c'est pas juste parce que c'est ce
que j'utilise à chaque fois on aggrave
ça et puis donc on aggrave sa et au delà
de ça en fait tout ce qui se passe c'est
qu'on nous une nouvelle partie du monde
à l'exploitation
là ce que vous voyez sur cette carte
c'est tout simplement deux grands
projets yamal lng qui en fait ces quatre
petits projet yamal lng 1 2 3 4 et
articles ng2 juste à côté l'un fait 27
milliards de dollars d'investissements
l'otan fait 21 ces deux grands projets
sont les grands projets emblématiques
des cinq dernières années en arctique
qui sont en train de se développer donc
c'est du gaz naturel liquéfié
l'idée c'est d'explorer et d'exploiter
ce qu'il ya en arctique est tout
simplement de l'exporter dans mon entier
à partir de l'arctique et pour ce faire
on a fait des méthaniers brise glace en
a fait des navires qui porte le glass
qui porte le gaz et qui brise la glace
tout seul mais les russes ils vont plus
loin ils sont en train de faire des
escortes de brise-glaces nucléaire avec
des bateaux avec deux moteurs nucléaire
dessus tout est normal
maintenant moi ce que je propose c'est
d'être plutôt optimiste là dessus c'est
à dire que je vous ai parlé l'hydrogène
depuis le début je vous ai parlé de
cette histoire d électrolyse
je vais paraître cette histoire de piles
à combustible et bien en fait en
arctique aujourd'hui vous pouvez
envisager c'est ce que font certaines
certains pays comme l'islande la norvège
la russie ou des états comme l'alaska
même le groenland qui disent mais nous
on a plein de ressources en énergies
renouvelables mais part de l'éolien pas
du solaire soutenir par des énergies
renouvelables qui nécessitent des terres
rares
on a tout simplement de
l'hydroélectricité la géothermie
bref quelque chose qui permet de
développer de l'hydrogène véritablement
vert à partir de l électrolyse de l'eau
et de manière abondante pas cher
et du coup l'idée c'est d'aller toucher
le ciel avec ça c'est de se dire si
véritablement on veut sauver l'arctique
gip a dit sue se sauver nous même si on
veut sauver l'arctique limit et no
impact sur la région
les animaux les peuples aux autochtones
et ainsi de suite
ce qu'il faut arriver à faire décarbonés
nos économies arrêtez d'utiliser des
carburants fossiles gaz du pétrole alors
le lng c'est bien parce que ça pollue 30
% de moins que le pétrole donc du coup
ça permet quand même de faire une
transition
c'est une énergie de transition et tous
les énergéticiens qui aujourd'hui se
focalise sur le gnl se disent
la prochaine étape c'est évidemment
l'hydrogène mais y'en a qui vont plus
loin et qu'il dise hydrogène il faut le
faire dès maintenant et on peut le faire
dès maintenant parce que contrairement
aux années 90 2000 ou encore avant
aujourd'hui petit à petit des
technologies deviennent de plus en plus
mature alors je sais pas si on va aller
avec cet hydrogène jusqu'à la nébuleuse
de l'hippocampe
mais en tout cas ce qui est certain
c'est que à partir de l'ipo mobile de
lenoir et jusqu'à notre exploration
spatiale sur la lune ou sur mars
on retrouve toujours l'hydrogène à un
moment où l'autre donc du coup ce que
j'avais envie de vous dire et s'il n'y a
qu'un seul message à garder de mon
intervention aujourd'hui c'est
simplement de vous dire la chose
suivante je sais pas ce que sera le
futur
mais ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
dans notre génération c'est à dire les
gens qui sont pas encore à la retraite
en 2050
eh bien nous on va voir l'émergence de
l'hydrogène et hydrogène sera très
certainement l'énergie qui fera la
transition énergétique c'est qu'il nous
permettra de dépasser le snow ball ifec
l'effet boule de neige qu'on a évoqué
tout à l'heure donc du coup pensé
hydrogène l'énergie number one
l'élément number one le premier vecteur
énergétique
pensez-y et pensez-y pas juste parce que
je voulais dit si vous ne croyez pas
vous pouvez aller lire des grands
économistes comme frédéric rifkin of
frédéric jeremy rifkin bien sûr qui en
2002 avait développé l'idée de la
société d'hydrogène
mais si vous n'êtes plus dans
l'imagination et dans la littérature
retournez en 1874 livre lire l'île
mystérieuse de jules verne
il en parle